[Music]
we all
watched the television
coverage of just yesterday that's on top
of everything else that we know and
don't know yet based on what we've just
been able to see and because we've seen
it or not doesn't mean it hasn't
happened what you just said is one of
the most insanely idiotic things I have
ever heard at no point in your rambling
incoherent response were you even close
to anything that could be considered a
rational thought everyone in this room
is now Dumber for having listened to it
I award you no points and may God have
mercy on your
soul
all right we are live on the interwebs
it's Friday which means it's time for
another Friday Round Table extravagance
joining me today is the president of the
Brownstone Institute Jeffrey Tucker and
lawyer for the Dylan Law Group and host
of Coleman Nation Podcast Ron Coleman
Jeffrey Ron welcome back to the Reuben
report it's nice to be here thanks Dave
guys before we get to anything and
obviously it's just another wacky week
in woke uh apparently in over the last
few hours there has been one of the
largest solar
flares uh I guess in the last decade or
so and people are predicting the systems
could go down I think we have some kind
of image of the solar flare uh so this
could be it for uh for the ruin report
and for all of us and I just want to say
it's an honor to have you guys on what
potentially could be our last program
it's a fitting
end it's a culmination if you will a
lifetime of fine work by all three of us
I would I would believe so uh Jeffrey is
in case the systems go out before we
even get to the show is there anything
you'd like to say just as sort of your
final summation of the whole thing you
know of the whole thing the whole
decline of civilization I will say that
that which everybody has a a different
beginning date uh mine is is March 13
20120 uh civilization was fun it was
glorious we did great things for a
thousand years you know but that's it
it's
over you're referencing uh the beginning
of covid well anyway we're going to do a
show and we'll see if the computer
machines and the wires make it happen uh
we're going to be talking about some of
the insane indoctrination on our college
campuses obviously which is now just
burst forth across Society uh a bit
about Hunter Biden's testimony and is
this the way the uh the Dems are going
to show Joe Biden the door cuz the polls
are not looking good and then just a bit
about what's going on over at the White
House as it relates to Christmas because
yes they brought in some drag queens
surprise surprise uh but what I thought
we could start talking about first today
is this video from Joe Rogan's show from
uh yesterday he's referencing this
former KGB agent Yuri bezmenov and I've
I've played a couple videos of this guy
who talks about how you would take out
Western civilizations how you could use
the media and the educational
institutions and over decades how you
could subvert all of our laws all of our
Norms all of the the good things about
our culture and just take us out without
even firing a shot uh Rogan referenced
that on his show yesterday I thought it
would be a nice place for us to start I
think I think there's been an
ideological capture of colleges and Yuri
bezoff the the former KGB guy from the
Soviet Union when he defected he talked
about this like openly that the Soviet
Union has been trying to do this forever
they've been trying to demoralize
America by infecting their educational
institutions and it's a
multigenerational approach you infect
the kids with Marxism and leninism in
the universities and then you
indoctrinate them to these ideas and
then they go off and slowly start to
seep into the workplace and over the
course of several Generations you
completely diminish their confidence in
democracy and what they think about
America you you destroy all of the
confidence said they have an America
that's exactly what's happening could be
when they're saying Osama Bin Laden was
correct I wish you would have said with
the Asian Mas damn it the mass is to it
was like too hard to form
sentences Jeffrey that kind of sounds
like what has happened here in America
as we watch all of these crazy protests
and everything else doesn't it I've been
a little bit shocked about the power of
of elite Academia over the culture I I
didn't expect it really to pan out this
way of course Buckley was complaining
about this in
1956 um and and we've been hearing about
this for decades but I was a little bit
uh dismissive of it in the past thinking
well who cares what goes on at Harvard
and Yale and Princeton whatever um these
you know nobody believes what the
professors say anyway we're going to
we're going to uh that's not really
going to matter so I've been a little
bit taken aback over the last several
years just to see the invasion of yes
all of the commanding Heights of society
by people who have been indoctrinated in
sort of extremist w ideology and I think
even more important than that they've
been denied access to the Western Cannon
you know that is that is long gone and
so it's not it's not so much the
presence of of woke Theory and
destructive
ideology um itself but the complete
absence of anything else anything like
Enlightenment thought uh you know
serious
literature um all the the great books
are just have been blasted away in the
21st century all the things that we
aspired the students everybody to learn
uh during the Progressive Era you know
with the with the great books and the
Harvard Classics it's all gone it's a
great it's a great Point actually
because what bz manov is saying what
Rogan's referencing is that they they
figured out a way to get into our
systems but you would think that our
systems which have done so our systems
our institutions our founding documents
which have done so much good over a
couple hundred years but really starting
with the Enlightenment and everything
else that they would have been able to
stand up to this but Ron I suspect as a
man who believes in some old books uh
you're not surprised perhaps well I'm I
am nonetheless surprised that so much
has collapsed so fast and one response
to that is well no around it has been so
fast at all it's like the over that's
what they say about the all the years it
takes to become an overnight
success uh I learned from uh from James
Lindsay about something that think I
had remembered from my cold war days as
you know I a lot of a lot of Kami stuff
um about how in fact the you know the
the
Soviet Communist Party made great
efforts to undermine American society
they focused they they realized as as he
explains that you couldn't really make a
strong class-based argument at the time
to Americans the way Marx predicted you
should be able to do in an
industrialized Society because Americans
were essentially a classless
society but they did realize that there
was real possibility in preaching
to
blacks and because blacks were quite
justifi justifiably alienated from the
mainstream of of American society they
were under under the the mores and the
law that existed at the time MH quite
meaningfully victims and there was some
it did take to some extent but Paul
Roberson aside and a handful of other
prominent black Communists aside it
didn't seem to have made that much of an
impact well it actually sort of did
because whether or not this was directed
by some Outside Agency or whether or not
it was or it was organic which I would
not dispute that that is the possibility
that actually ends up what being what
happens what we did see by the Justified
focus on civil rights was a door was
opened to not only leftist activism and
Marxist and what many of us call
cultural
Marxism but we also saw the profound
effect of guilt on the American liberal
psyche in a way that had never really
been reckoned with before and whether
whether the Tipping Point on that is is
Hiroshima or Vietnam or or any number of
other things or whether it's all of them
put
together the the people the majority the
elite the original Elite the WASP Elite
that was so
fundamental as a Cornerstone in American
Society lost the will to to do what it
had to to do to protect to protect
itself against being absolutely not only
undermined
but replaced and made irrelevant let me
pause you there for a second because
this this thing that you just mentioned
about guilt and that there were
legitimate things obviously with the
Civil Rights Movement at first but then
the liberal Elites didn't know what to
do with the guilt of some of the things
that had happened in the past well
here's Yuri bezmenov himself explaining
how ideological subversion can basically
lead to the complete taking down of a
society ideological subversion that is a
phrase that uh I'm afraid some Americans
don't fully understand when uh the
Soviets use the phrase ideological
subversion what do they mean by
ideological subversion is is the slow
process which we call either ideological
subversion or active measures AC in the
language of of the KGB or psychological
warfare what it basically means is to
change the perception of reality of
every American to such an extent that
despite of the abundance of
information no one is able to come to
sensible conclusions in the interest of
Defending themselves their families
their community and their
country it's a great
brainwashing uh process which goes very
slow and it's divided in in four basic
stages uh the first one being
demoralization it takes from 15 to 20
years to de moralize a nation why that
many years because this is the minimum
number of years which requires to
educate one generation of
students in the country of of of your
enemy exposed to the ideology of the
enemy in other words Marxism leninism
ideology is being pumped into the soft
heads of of of at least three
generations of American students without
being challenged or counterbalanced by
the basic values of
americanism the line that gets me there
and there's an awful lot that's chilling
is he says that you'll get to a point
where no one is able to come to sensible
conclusions so let me throw real quick
to a pramas rally at Columbia University
just in the last couple
days Jeffrey you referenced before you
were a believer in these institutions
you didn't think that they were going to
uh collapse so quickly or that they
would stand up for themselves a little
bit better it's quite an admission it's
I appreciate it and I and a lot of
people I think felt that um when you see
this and by the way I have no problem
calling them Pro Hamas rallies because
nobody there is going to condemn Hamas I
a lot of people give me crap for that I
if you don't believe so feel free to say
um but isn't that the perfect
culmination of everything that Yuri bov
is talking about yeah it probably is you
know I think part of the problem here by
the way why are they all wearing masks
are they are they a fit of Co I I don't
it's a fine line from The covid Mask to
the full burka and everything
else or maybe it's just a symbol right I
mean like if you're if you're on the
left you have to wear a mask as a way of
telling friends and neighbors where you
stand I don't I don't understand how the
mask became this um but you know part of
the problem here uh Dave is that we are
sending we're trying to send 50% of the
students to uh to schools that for which
they pay uh six figures and many more
left with vast amounts of debt and then
sending them out into the workplace to
take 10% of the jobs that are available
and they're angry they feel like they've
been lied to they they're wasting their
time in vast majority of the waste of
their time in these universities
learning gibberish so um so they're
angry at the world it's like they feel
they have a sense that it's broken and
they're desperate for meaning in their
lives so these crazy causes and these
crazy protests give this dopamine rush
and this sense that they can make a
difference by being insane because
they're they're basically lashing out at
at the at the system that they think and
in many cases rightly has has robbed
them of of a meaningful life or any
other purpose in in life and I think
it's really tragic and that that
demographic sort of
um that that uh uneven balance there
that we're sending so many kids to
school to and spinning so much money on
it to learn to get education they're not
actually going to use professionally um
I is has got to be part of this problem
just least loss of confidence and a loss
of purpose and a loss of meaning and
it's exactly what bezmenov said that you
should do if you wanted to take out a
country Ron you're going to love this
one uh because I know you're a man of
higher education at the University of
Pennsylvania they have started a
coalition uh Freedom School uh to defend
freedom of speech as it relates to
Palestine or something like that good
luck trying to make sense of this and
has consistently sidelined marginalized
communities this undergraduate student
wanted to remain anonymous but says that
concern with the university is the
reason they've started the Coalition
Freedom School of Palestine we hope this
Freedom School will be a platform where
in students where we can Elevate
Palestinian voices the group is calling
on pen to demand a cease fire protect
freedom of speech on campus and
Institute freedom of thought for
Palestine we reach out to pen about the
demonstration and the response to the
group's demands but have not heard back
yet as for the pro Palestinian group
they plan to continue making their
voices heard no matter what This Is Why
We Gather here today is because we want
to wake up but we can still make a
change we want to wake up while we can
still make a difference we want to wake
up while we can still Save a
Life take it away
Ron look
look there we are in a an intellectual
regime of
utter inanity and our time and one thing
I like about Jeff's formulation is that
it
gives some credit to these
lunatics uh of being premised on the
idea that they are insightful and that
they they're aware on some level of the
of the emptiness inside of them uh I'm
not so sure that the students at ivy
league universities and and all right
let's include Penn I it's a member part
it's part of the ivy league but you know
we never really respected it all that
much at Princeton um
but in all
seriousness I think there is an
expectation among this particular cadra
the IV League schools and and MIT and
you know the other Stanford and the like
Chicago these Elite schools the these
students I think
actually do have an empty core but they
don't feel that I don't believe that
they feel that frustration that
innumerable other college students who
are wasting their time in college and
they're wasting their time every bit as
much from an educational point of view
and from an and an
intellectual training point of view
which is at least as important as the
content part or the Mastery part subject
matter
stuff the students in these Elite
institutions have
been conditioned to think of themselves
and and the IV League schools reinforce
this during the time that you're there
as the decision
makers as the people who are entitled to
and will run the
world and
they don't like the fact that the things
that they have been taught shouldn't be
happening shouldn't be allowed to be
happening are
happening and yes this does give them a
chance to act out and feel meaning but I
don't think it's because they're angry
for themselves I think it's because I
think that there might be an anger there
but but I think it's because they they
are like children who are are not
getting the you know they they don't
want that TV show to be on they want a
toy that they can't have right in
essence in essence they've been taught
all the wrong things given none of the
right tools now they're seeing reality
and they think they have dominion over
it I want to show you one more image
from an Ivy League school this one's
from Harvard and Harvard's had a pretty
bad week and you can see these students
there and a lot of them again the mask
thing and okay genocide occupied River
to the Sea all of the all of the stuff
Jeffrey make some sort of case if you
can why we shouldn't just be excited for
Harvard to completely collapse on top of
the fact that the well on top of I know
they have a $50 billion endowment so
it's going to take a little time because
you can throw cash at things to keep it
going but on top of the fact that you
know claudi and gay the president is now
also it is very clear that she
plagiarized in her dissertation and and
everything else like why just makes is
there any argu left why anyone should
care about these no no it's it's
astonishing I the the case of this
plagiarism stuff she should have
immediate well she should have never
been appointed to that position but but
now that we have all this proof I mean
it's overwhelming it's not just 4 case
it's not just 14 Cas it's everywhere I
mean you can't even look through her
work without bumping into another case
of plag it's so obvious it wasn't a
mistake she should have resigned the
fact that she didn't and she stole from
a black woman by the way Carol who is a
well-known academic so meanwhile you've
got these Sor interrupt but You' got the
NAACP saying that if you go after gay
you're a white supremacist but she stole
from the black yeah it's just it's
unbelievable how everybody should have
rallied around her I I do want to say
somebody else about these with these
kids and they they're claiming uh fre
Freedom I'm I'm weirdly happy to hear uh
words like freedom and Free Speech I
don't understand where these same people
were during lockdowns during the vaccine
mandates when they were being imprisoned
in their dormitories when they were
being robbed of their tuition uh by
being forced onto Zoom classes I mean
they were compl
completely passive uh vast numbers of of
IV League professors administrators and
students were passive in the face of
these tyrannical
controls uh in the name of controlling
infective infectious disease and had as
far as I could tell like no nothing to
say about it and the few who did were
severely oppressed and some of them were
just tossed out of school well let's
just face it you had to go along with
the vax mandate or you weren't allowed
to stay there and they were these were
despotic where were the protests they
had nothing that would have been a nice
opportunity to talk about freedom and
human right it's an interesting it's an
interesting concept when when the Need
For Freedom was at their door literally
they did nothing and folded and now they
have this abstract concept of Freedom
across the world that's completely
backwards actually but this is how
they're expressing it I will I will
ruminate on that one over the weekend
Jeffrey you've done well but let's move
to the next topic here uh Hunter Biden
the son of Joe Biden and Joe loves this
boy you must know that he really loves
him that's what they tell us on The View
every day uh he was on Capitol Hill
yesterday explaining that everything
going on with him and his business
dealings and his father and a potential
impending impeachment is really because
Maga is a bunch of crazy people for six
years Maga Republicans including members
of the House committees who are in a
closed door session session right now
have imputed my character
invaded my privacy attacked my wife my
children my family and my
friends theyve ridiculed my struggle
with
addiction they belittled my
recovery and they have tried to
dehumanize me all to embarrass and
damage my
father who has do devoted his entire
public life to service oh God I I just
looked Conor my D It's funny everyone's
body language right now because I just
looked at Connor in my director in the
middle of that and I always forget if
you guys are muted if we're all muted
during these things cuz all look Ron's
crying we were all laughing hysterically
through that unfortunately everyone was
muted I may have to change how we do
that going forward my favorite part of
that uh these Maga people have imped the
character of the man who is looking for
crack cocaine out of the carpet to smoke
like parmesan cheese Ron as a
former how can you ridicule this man's
struggle with with a substance
addiction that's really vicious of you I
can't believe it Ron I didn't mean to
interrupt you Ron go ahead I'm what
exactly is the qu I mean there I can
anywh it's just the the sheer lunacy of
everything no matter what light they
shine on why did this guy have a job at
barisma and he had no business working
at an energy company and who was he giv
the money to and the dad firing them
this is all just about Maga and they're
being mean because you know they're not
paying enough for his artwork or
something Mr chairman as an Italian
American I resent your question about
the
Mafia That's I mean this is th this is
just so transparent and it feeds into
into you know into the the yenta class
you know over at at at at the view and
and those kind of nonsense people I mean
everything is a game everything is a
spin there you know this is all his way
of saying I'm not going to answer answer
questions that I'm legally obligated
under a subpoena to answer and that
people have gone to
prison not only within our lifetimes
within the last several months yeah for
not for not obeying I'm a Biden I'm
separate and any any attempt to apply to
me the same rules that apply to any
other member of civilization are just
magaly
things uh oh speaking of magal lunacy I
think the demons in oh maybe the solar
flare is starting oh God the solar flare
Jeffrey it's just me and you unless the
solar flare Jeffrey we lost everybody
all right we're going to try to
reconnect with people I think what Ron
was about to say is that it's a whole
bunch of BS and they're just Li you know
what what the hunters in essence doing
is just making a whole bunch of
nothingness so that the what he calls
the yenta class which I like that phrase
It's Like The View will talk about it oh
he's he's the victim here he's the
victim here can we jump to the other
Clips while we're trying to reconnect I
want to show you something else
uh that's really just incredible so the
New York Times was covering the very
press conference that Hunter Biden was
having right there and I want to show
you listen to Hunter Biden talk about
his father's involvement or not
involvement first then I want to show
you the way the New York Times covered
it so check the video first I am
here let me State as clearly as I
can my father was not financially
involved in my
business now I want to show you
something read the words that the New
York Times put in their quote you're
going to have to pay close attention
here we're going to show you the video
again the New York Times this is how
they covered it I am here let me State
as clearly as I can my father was not
involved in my business now we're going
to play the video for you again and see
if you can figure out what word the New
York Times left out of that quote I am
here let me State as clearly as I
can my father was not financially
involved in my
business you see what the New York Times
Did there they took the word financially
out in the quote so the average person
reading the paper wouldn't see
financially now it might be true to some
extent in the most sort of like strict
legal sense that Joe Biden was not
involved financially meaning that he
didn't write the contracts in everything
but was he you know the contract that
say got Hunter bite in the job at
barisma but was he involved D
financially in The Meta sense like why
did Hunter have the job in the first
place of course he was involved
financially we know that there are also
Financial records of Hunter Biden paying
Joe Biden money and Joe Biden then using
some of the money to say give Hunter
Biden this freaking house in Delaware
and all all of the stuff but putting all
of the details aside do you see how I
know you guys see it do you see how the
New York Times runs cover for the
Democrats that's just one of a million
examples uh we are trying to get the uh
the guys back is this the solar flare
like if this is the end I don't know
that I want to spend my last few minutes
talking about Hunter Biden like there's
a whole bunch of other stuff I'd rather
be telling people about what if this is
really the end guys I hope everyone's
enjoying themselves as you're watching
this like the zombies are coming the
aliens are here and you guys are
watching me talk about Hunter um wait
let me jump over to do we have one more
on hunter or no that was it on Hunter
right yeah all right we're going to try
to get the guys back so let me go let me
run on this for two more minutes if we
don't get them then uh we'll do segment
three just solo I think I think I can do
a solo show I've done it once or twice
before um the real question that I think
is happening right now is what is is
this you know impending impeachment non
impeachment because obviously Joe Biden
is not going to be impeached but
whatever is going on with under Biden is
this the way that the system is slowly
showing Joe Biden the door you know
there have been a lot of polls you guys
know my feelings about polls but there
have been a lot of polls in the last
week showing that Trump will beat Biden
rather handily doesn't matter if they're
true or not that's what's in The Ether
of the system right now that Trump is
going to beat Biden everyone knows that
Biden is not cognitively aware there's
no real movement behind him you can feel
because of everything that's happened
over the last two plus months since
October 7th a lot of whatever's left of
that same liberal class is kind of
waking up and could potentially vote
Republican so the Democrats are
definitely feeling like what do we have
to do here but they as you guys know
they have a huge problem on their hands
because not only do you have to figure
out a way to get rid of Joe Biden so you
could maybe get him involved in this
Scandal and then he steps down he does
the right thing it's honorable he steps
down I didn't really realize what my son
was doing and how some of this had
happened or or I'm just not guilty at
all but it's time to move on but then
the bigger problem they have is Camala
Harris the woman that we showed you that
insane cold open of she's waiting in the
wings and and there's just virtually
nobody in America that wants to vote for
her so if they think if they're looking
at the numbers and they think that
they're in trouble with Joe Biden
they're in way more trouble when it
comes to Camala Harris so then the
question is well what do you have to do
to get rid of her do you get do you do
some brokered convention like what is
the thing I do not know but I I do
strongly sense and usually I'm usually
as my friend Eric Weinstein always says
about me Dave you're directionally right
more than most people I do think that
they are trying they're just seeding the
ground with a little we are going to get
rid
of uh Joe Biden and let's kind of figure
out how we're going to do it I think
we're yeah I think we have Ron back
let's see if we can bring Ron back in
damn solar flares Ron do we have
you we do not have
Ron the solar flares damn all right all
right I'm gonna finish up segment three
without the guys and we will bring them
back soon enough um the one other thing
that I did want to cover this week it's
sort of it's sort of silly on on its
face in some sense but I think it also
gets to the cultural rot that we were
talking about and and everything that
Yori bov was talking about about how you
can just sort of slowly destroy
everything uh I want you to watch this I
we played a clip of this on people of
the internet yesterday it's just wild
this is Jill Biden this is from Dr Jill
Biden the wife of the president of the
United States from her official Twitter
account uh this is the debut of the
White House Christmas decor and
celebration hold on to your hats
[Music]
folks
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
it never ends people that goes on for 87
hours we just clipped it for you all
right you might be watching that going
Dave don't be outraged about this why
are you trying to make me Outrage about
some silly little white house thing okay
maybe there was a drag queen in there or
whatever tap dancing's not so terrible
and you'd be right except of course what
did we find out this morning this is
from End wokeness Breaking the group
behind the viral Biden Christmas video
is a radical anti-white group called
dorance dance on the group website they
call for defunding the police abolishing
prisons and even quote Marxist terrorist
Angela Davis the site has an entire
section dedicated to
anti-white literature so regardless of
whether you think it's tacky to have
them tap dancing and the guy dressed as
a woman and all the sort of over-the-top
ridiculousness and that's kind kind of
what's filled up everything these days
culturally um maybe they could have
found another group that tap dances that
aren't so inlined with Marxist are there
any tap dancing groups that aren't
Marxist Brock you're the tap dancing
specialist here do you know any
non-marxist tap dancing groups you have
to be you oh apparently now you have to
be a Marxist to be a tap dancer well
there you go uh I want to contrast that
to Melania white Melania
White
Melania trumps White Christmas
go
[Music]
Melania Whit's beautiful Christmas there
you have it anyway it's not time to
really get your panties in a bunch other
than it does show the kind of cultural
rot that has just infected absolutely
everything and I was looking forward to
discussing that uh with the guys but
alas the solar flares I mean how I mean
this is seriously ironic like there are
all these warnings about solar flares
and the internet's about to go down
apparently Skype is down uh many of you
from our locals Community are probably
watching this on Rumble right now
because locals went down for a little
bit they're still doing some back-end
stuff over there but who I mean weird
times weird times on this Friday uh
anyway I guess get out there and maybe
get some water and tuna I feel like tuna
you just should have a lot of tuna and
then you know if all hell breaks loose
it's months later and all you've eaten
is tuna you probably die of mercury
poisoning rather than being eaten alive
by the zombies that seems right to me
well that's an odd ending for a holiday
seasonal
show uh my full interview with Caroline
Glick who's really she's a spectacular
actual journalist she's on the ground in
Israel and I tried to do the interview a
little bit differently and not just get
into the political portion but what it's
like to actually live in a country going
through War uh it's about a 20-minute
interview really enjoyed talking to her
that's up across platforms right now as
always uh our new Twitter account uh at
Ruben report show is up where you can
get direct clips of the show and we have
no postgame show because of the solo
flare so um good luck with all of that
see you let me State as clearly as I
can my father was financially involved
in my business the Kickbacks we got paid
for my new teeth these hair plugs that
obviously didn't work countless hookers
and all the parmesan cheese a guy could
ask for and my dad the big guy said it
best I'm the smartest guy he
knows